welcome to podcast Ville the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by listen like I tell Li what good is
watching the games if you're not gonna
start making money my book e dot AG is
the industry leading website that'll
hook you up with all your betting needs
you understand me
I mean why have a winner if you can't
put in with somebody and collect the Vig
that's what I'm talking about
join now what I'm gonna do for you is
this go to my bookie dot AG take a look
you join now and my bookie will match
your deposit up to one percent bonus use
promo code Church CH you are CH to
activate the offer visit my bookie dot
AG and use promo code Church you play
you win you get paid you watch the game
you put it on my bookies dot AG and your
take a nap you wake up boom your money's
in the bank that's what I'm talking
about go to my bookies out AG use promo
code Church and they'll match your
deposit with up to one hundred percent
bonus also this podcast is brought to
you by on it on it is a leader in
supplements from new Moo - shroom tech
sport - shroom tech up immune you will
be in shock of the results go to
Hahnenkamm right now and press in search
boom and get 10% off your first order
delivered to your house kick this
[ __ ] mule Lee
you
filthy animals uncle Joey here Churchill
what's happened
thank you for joining us we got Felicia
Michaelson house what's up you sexy so
everything Joey just being a mom Joe mom
right chicks now you guys good movie in
a festival congratulations thank you I
have a documentary in the festival the
documentary is called pervs and it's at
the La Femme International Film Festival
here in Los Angeles this Friday at the
Regal theatres downtown at 6 o'clock so
if you ain't doing dick come on down
[ __ ] it's no it's in a real movie
theater has to be like the dream of
every anything it's like a real legit
movies theater you get to have popcorn
and it's like yeah because everyone like
you and it's cool to like if you're in a
class or even if you have like a small
screening but to be in like a movie
theater were like Star Wars in here I
was in a festival once it was like
someone's fancy garage and you're like
really there's a couple good ones in
town that you go to you buy a pass and
you cancel a [ __ ] a movie that's what
those things are for so you get to see
different [ __ ] people you're down
there spending the day I'm sure - well
as festival right for women directors
and producers and so Susanna Lee who is
in the movie who was on the podcast cast
very funny chick [ __ ] she's kind of the
star of the movie and she also helped me
produce it so I was like I should
totally submit to this festival and we
got in I was always shocked because the
movies pretty dirty so I was pretty
surprised but it got in it's not that
it's dirty it shows a part it showed us
listen you see strip club is mainstream
you watch movies right you know was
going on strip club there's always a
hooker involved there's always a chick
we were watching payback the other day
with Lucy Liu how God was she whips
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] is great but you
never see the crack of porn and the
crowd of porn is the dollar thing but
four corners in the [ __ ] boot
and the window goes people [ __ ] funny
it was only a dollar when I was a child
when I was eleven you know a nickel I
played hooky and you went down to 42nd
Street and you you fear an [ __ ] like
you wanted to the they had these stores
that sold IDs and then they also sold
maps
yeah - the best porno places in
Manhattan like 1970 you go - that was
the epoch or center of sex like you know
is that in Las Vegas 42nd Street in New
York which we you walk down now and you
see all these [ __ ] Disney things that
was the epic or as sex when you got off
that bus at Port Authority right across
the street from there was were the Laugh
Factory what an years ago before that
was that was porn world or sex world yes
Times Square
yeah that's Time Square and when you
walk down that thing I used to get off
that [ __ ] bus you know and coming
from Jersey and I'd get off that thing
and I'd stop there you know maybe I'll
get a hot dog at 8:00 in the morning I
see an Arab with those [ __ ] tails
they sell those cat tails they sell on
the stick
absolutely and they put a little piece
of bread on there you put some Frank's
hot sauce you kill all the germs you're
good to go for two dollars I would stand
and eat those and watch who wouldn't old
going there and who will come out of it
and that's where I was wrong
it wasn't the crack of porn it was
executives attorneys that go in there
get their [ __ ] you can't get your
dick sucked and live it's a poor place
so poor place euh one-man show unless
someone some little gay guys in there
and you get to talk about the sucking
your dick for three hours with me the
first time you actually get into a place
that yeah really and they just would let
you in or just sneak in listen it was 19
[ __ ] 70 something yeah what they
didn't see get it no and they didn't
want to know so you walked in and there
was a guy with benthos tokens either
have a belt on like a Chris Rock would
make the change for those tokens so if
you're eight if you're 13 and you go in
there with a dollar building a table get
the [ __ ] out of it
but if you're 13 you walk in there with
a 20 yeah well he talks [ __ ] I would
get Lee's 5 by 5
your son's 5 and the other 5 and we go
over there and that's how you 5 come up
to me at 20 because when I walk in he's
gonna give me changed you guys gonna be
walking behind me they wouldn't proof
yes so as long as the guy was busy well
I just tell you what he did to see he
didn't want to see so if you were
getting stabbed in the corner in those
days he wouldn't look up he would keep
making you change it was one of those
dude that that was the place right there
on eighth Avenue
I'm telling you that that was it so when
you win in did you go by yourself or
with your friends I won before of us
play hooky you know you're in the eighth
grade
you got that shitty weed from High Times
you know high tide ourselves
Invitational weed in the back the
seventies they did it they did so you
would send the 395 and then you got back
this way too didn't you and your buddies
plant that play hooky and smoke this
weed when you went to smoke you got
[ __ ] beat Felicia walk now what we
gonna do we have plans let's go into the
city uh-huh so you took a bus into
Manhattan you know hit you're in the
seventh grade how old do you interceptor
great Wow yeah 12 or 13 and we'd walk
right to Port Authority and it was like
your sensory overload of your ears once
you hit Broadway okay see you got off
the bus on eighth Avenue and you went to
the corner we'd be giggling four or five
or six kids then you cross the street to
42nd Street you walked up once you came
on in that turn at the Broadway there
was 50 yards there we you heard it was
mind-boggling I wish you know I had the
audio of little guys but this is exactly
what you would hear you ready money one
acid
THC heroin Perico Perico Perico
marijuana cocaine inna oriya tango no
either in Spanish in English you would
hear this for five minutes while you
were walking I never forget walking
through the city with my mother like to
go see a Disney movie like the Love Bug
and those five minutes were treacherous
and the cops wouldn't do nothin to you
New York City was an adventure for a
child and what
Broadway was a completely different city
so once she went through 50 yards or
money one a heroin cocaine I got pills
dog I got pills dog now you stepped into
three-card Monte land so it was two or
three blocks of three-card Monte are
afters and they wouldn't stomp on kids
were nearby that was part of it they
wanted to come kids yeah is the way we
are they didn't give a [ __ ] you know 30
years ago you would smoke with your kid
in the car 60 years ago
no see smoke while you were pregnant you
know and give you kid paint chips and
they were fine
are you kidding when my mom was pregnant
with my brother they she was overweight
they prescribed speed so she would lose
weight while she was pregnant is like a
hyperactive kid yeah so you bet it would
be New York City would be wild but to
get back to Felicia's question you would
tear the back I would give everybody
their five hours and tokens because they
gave you special tolerance but they were
worth like a quarter apiece and
basically you got like I don't know a
number right here maybe you got 30
seconds per token oh really
yes well here you always find out that
do all four of you and then you lock the
door you walk in and your feet would
sink in a half inch of sperm that they
just couldn't wipe up so many people
jerk off in there it's such a high rate
that the sperm will caligula and you
would walk in there and be like you ever
walk in the snow after it's four days
old frozen like you're there's different
points I'm not giving you Lee
and before you went in there remember
Lee before you won in this how
disgusting yeah none of this sounds fun
no no but it is fun it is fun 2012 okay
when you're 12 and you'll see a guy come
out of a room and a little immigrant
walk in with a [ __ ] with hot water
and wipe up to come and then he puts it
back in the thing and he goes go right
ahead you know like you're like oh like
we're not when you tip him like a token
or some oh go away
come up for a [ __ ] living you can't
you're not even invited to the
conversation what do you do for a living
I'm a janitor come house that was this
guy's he got eight bucks an hour
insurance you know it was steaming he
just plop it on the club like this and
then pull anything and squeeze it and
then you go in there you put your token
in there and the [ __ ] screen will pop
okay so they would probably be if it was
eight them what if it was telling them
oh my god if it was ten in the morning
there's already like a collaboration of
come on the fall it's open 24 hours and
then we never close will I [ __ ] the
Vatican we don't close that like a
Comedy Store someone probably drown in
there one yeah no not only and if you
won in there at six
it was chicks that will hook in that
[ __ ] all night long and that one in
there for the last twenty dollars and
they would be all high and [ __ ] some guy
would be putting a dick in her mouth and
she would be on a circular bed that
wasn't even made it was like a circular
bed now this is in the peep show in the
peep show so you you either went to the
peep shows were either singular or
plural the plural ones were a circle so
you could second Sealy oh no I can look
at leek and Sealy looking at your [ __ ]
my brain doesn't talk the way walking
home Lee I saw you jerking off of that a
jerk-off
I swear to God smell my head you know
and that's the creepiest conversations
at 12-year old stupid my hand you know
it was [ __ ] crazy yeah but then they
had the glass they had first let me be
clear on this they had the shield that
went up and it was a bulletproof glass I
think God okay then there was if you
went into 42nd Street and you wanted
nose those are the ones with everything
popped up and you could stick your hand
and she would come over and let you suck
at it fing uh you know you could figure
out why you jerked off but you had a
like put your arm in this little glass
uh-huh okay she would have to get like a
milk like a like in the bank
and you would be fingered you could suck
it to these you can lick her [ __ ]
like she would have to bend over on the
milk cart and she just she I just got in
from but I never went to that one with a
head popped up I never went in with a
glass popped it right but so we went the
first time we went back to Jersey talked
about it Jesus Christ probably [ __ ]
right in front of you come on you're
lying you're fully [ __ ] now bad they
[ __ ] front in the bag that's made of
wooden it spins uh-huh I tell you that
go around while the guy was [ __ ] her
so what do you have to move his feet
like she'd be on him and he'd just be
[ __ ] and she would know where she'd
be and then while he was [ __ ] her
there'd be three chicks going around
like if a bunch of chicks came yeah then
it was like a suck I thought my kid for
a quarter Wow but then I went back we
started going back back back and I went
with a kid who today is a cop to San
Diego and this [ __ ] knucklehead stuck
his head in and didn't put enough corn
is it so the thing closed and they had
to call an ambulance we all left him
there we didn't no no no no I still
dragging them out where are you guys
God how would you like that hanging on
you for the rest of high school so that
was the bottom level yeah when you made
the turn up Felicia I'm looking in the
eye and I'm telling you this because you
have boys and I just wanted to let you
know how happy you didn't raise your
boys in New York at this time so that as
you walked up as you got close to
Caroline's
I didn't know was Carolyn's I'm not
gonna sit I don't know nothing about
family do I give a [ __ ] about comedy but
as you got up in those streets all those
bars with those bars might come in to be
a black eye outside or a hot chick I
should go come on in
Felicia do you know how many times they
drugged us and then we were seven
through the eighth grade
really yeah well right up to the bar you
guys all know what the grip oh yeah we
all love to drink and strippers come
right up
sit next gen you could feel their leg we
would be like [ __ ] 12 and he's one
more 40 whoa whoa nice fears I want to
tell another hooking career you can feel
their leg and then they go we could have
a damp you have to buy me a bottle of
champagne there was a little little
bottle oh okay here you are in the
seventh grade they come back with a $41
time and you're like give me that you
want you drinking that $40 I ain't got
40 a husband oh yeah right we did that
at all those places yeah well they would
call us in think about that that's how
raw yeah New York City was the sound is
I I can imagine that's right because
when I I'm an army brat so I grew up in
Berlin my mother was from Berlin my
father was in the service and when they
got divorced we lived on the street
called puts dumbest Raza which was like
that one of the main streets in Berlin
and in the 70s it was at the same time
as what you're talking about there were
prostitutes and hookers all over the
place and it was like just out in the
open and one time I was walking home
from school or something in this
prostitute ran to catch the bus but you
know you could tell she's prostitute and
her necklace fell off and I picked it up
and I gave it to my mom for Mother's Day
I still have that [ __ ] necklace from
some hooker of crazy in Berlin but it
but it was very raw back then yeah you
know in those days a lot of kids I hung
out with their dads would take them into
the city get laid for the first time
just to get out of the way that's kind
of weird that was very bad back that way
nobody ever did it with me
Oh age 14 oh really a lot of kids I grew
up with what about the poor prostitute I
mean $50 is $50 maybe they'd she didn't
do it a lot maybe they didn't do it a
lot cuz they got really young ones do it
like I can't imagine like a 30 year old
I'm sure they draw out the oldest ones
especially ones growing Manhattan
Spanish families love the Spanish for
their dads would take them right down
they get to get it out of the way so
that's it we don't have this problem oh
you want to [ __ ] your brother well it's
a you know sexuality is so weird right
like like I see when you when you're a
mom and you have kids and you see like
like one child is more sexual in nature
than another child who's to say like
what is a deviant behavior in sex and
what is not deviant behavior in sex and
to bring it back to the movie when
Susana Lee who is a comedian and sex
worker on the side she was working at
the Venus Fair show they're a peep show
it's the last working peep show in the
Los Angeles County area because a lot of
that stuff is going away you know and
she's like I wanted to do this I had
this idea for a web series I want to
interview comedians and we want to talk
about deviants and sexuality and all
that do you want to be a part of that
and I was like yeah I want to be a part
of it I think that's really just out of
the park and as a lot of people kind of
know I was a stripper when I was 18 so
for me it was like [ __ ] yeah I wanted to
see the inside of one of those I want to
go and then she had a girl that was
filming it but the girl didn't know what
she was doing and then before I went for
my interview say oh no we can't do it
because it's [ __ ] up all the footage
they had Margaret Cho and everything got
screwed up and I said if I bring you
know funding will you let me direct it
and so that's how I got into doing pervs
and so we meant made this webseries
starting to make it and we have a Paul
Provenza you came and did it Felipe
Esparza came and did a lot of women
Lauri Kilmartin came and did all these
people came and did it and it was such
an interesting thing because you would
like Jimmy Schubert did it you would
think there were people that could come
into the booth and be interviewed by a
comedian about comedy and deviance and
she gives them a Peep Show at the same
time you would think how boisterous some
of the guys are that they'd be able to
deal with it
it was really cool to see who can really
deal with it and who can't and who is a
secret perv and who isn't you know what
I mean and it's so way different than
what you expect like you're talking
about your friend that is now policemen
in San Diego like you guys went through
this really creepy deviant teenage
period and how for some people it's not
their lifestyle even though they
experiment with it and and I can't even
imagine being 13 and 14 and my first
time at sexuality is at a place like
that I can't even imagine what do you
take away from that how [ __ ] up it
must make you in the in a sense right
but all that to me is so fascinating and
not even that you just saw sex because
that would have blown my mind but like
plunk stars for the most part are very
like good-looking you saw like people
were drugged up like what did the guy
look like the guy couldn't have been on
drugs - right like a little you know
what the Jersey those kids were active
active in every single way that home
they boys and it was always like we're
always up to something and that was one
of the things we were up to we won't
have to born again when we were younger
Felicia you could go into a back of
Penthouse and get three what super 8 all
right super 8 it was called reel to reel
3.0 movies with $20 and they sent you a
little [ __ ] makeshift projector that
was a piece of [ __ ] so that was another
thing we did we ordered that one time
and we took up to my attic and we
watched him and it was I wish that porn
was still around to show people what
porn from the late sixties and seventies
look like was not gentle it was just
horrific it was that stuff was horrific
it was just mortifying the more I think
about it today I'm like yeah I even
wrote a bit about it that game with a
little justice I liked a bit because I
would say Jesus I gave that such a funny
tape but it wasn't funny
it was so unfunny that one of the
younger kids in the room started crying
that's how unfunny it was like the guy's
dick was big
she put [ __ ] jelly on it and put two
pieces of white bread on his day but
it's had been sucked out Felicia they
looked like men's tits like look like my
chest she must have been 23 you know she
didn't she was a missing teeth but she
had an overbite
you could hear the director giving her
instructions like sucked a dick like she
would have like it was crazy yeah and
then he would put the dick in her face
and then she grabbed it and the guy's
dick was jolly Gant thick like that's an
inmate super dicks like 16 inches like
this thing was this big and that's not
what they settled on her and jelly and
peanut butter and jelly get a piece of
like she put two pieces of bread up and
there was still six inches hanging out
of his day that's how big this guy's
dick we all sat down like that at all
and that was that do you think when you
guys were doing it at that age obviously
you have a tremendous curiosity and an
area but do you think that it got to the
point where you guys were ordering films
and doing all that just because it's
one-upping each other and just no
training we do it together as partners
but just egging each other on you're
like and then we got as we like once we
got the freshman year that's the same
crew was together and now we'd add that
would raise the stakes on that trip we
just no angel dust jeez and then watch
porn know go into the city okay no they
go here it's important yes six five six
fourteen year old maybe one fifteen year
old angel dust which is just a blur so
then I would go with someone II wanna be
even raise the stakes look all right
here's what we're doing Yulia Felicia
I'll see you guys later
what do you mean meet Carlos and Jimmy
and I go this way we'll meet you at four
o'clock at bought a thorium 181st Street
it's 48th Street we're gonna meet you in
three hours nights eleven we'll meet you
five hours
we take a trans kids you know many
things gonna happen to you the only
[ __ ] idea Felicia a trains give them
a train to the Bronx with junkies nod
girl the train with three of us like
giggling [ __ ] but I've been going to the
city since the fifth grade fourth grade
that was what I do on the weekends my
mom had no [ __ ] idea what would you
do up there in the city when I was walk
around a slice of pizza like you have no
[ __ ] idea what can happen to obtain
those days so do you just say you
snorted Angeles first yeah it's not
angel dust first we got an angel dust
the end of freshman year normal but then
it was huge it was $10 for a bag and
three people who get I I mean [ __ ] up
okay what kind of high was that like
Gumby meaning 10 volumes it's like
eating a bunch of valiums and the Muslim
your life is flashing like the whole day
is just flashing my kids a slash and
you're [ __ ] high you know you're
Gumby that's what we call it Gumby dust
you would just Gumby yeah and we'd walk
those streets in New York get involved
in three-card Monte is taking a train
get off by see the sign Avalon their
65th Street we'd walk around there we'd
see if we get we any [ __ ] things
happen to me 13 you're trying to get
[ __ ] we in the city and we get it and
then we go up to a platform they would
show up we go to OTB off-track badges
going there you know many things have
happened to you that's pedophile right
off-track betting is pedophile vote
what's in that time period what's the
worst trouble you guys ever got into and
not trouble like where you got caught
but the worst situation where you had
fear of like this is no strip clubs we
know in the would lure you in and you go
in then sit next to him at the bar and
then they come with a bottle of
champagne those bottles of 20-something
box band and the [ __ ] bouncers will
go with the [ __ ] you guys don't have no
money empty your [ __ ] pockets so we
go in there with money already in our
socks like we were just [ __ ] you know
crazy at that age you know we but
I still remember like just we've talked
about those pictures before that was why
when you did the fellow mother very
interested I go wow and that was an
older style that one had a thick
bulletproof glass
yeah the machine on the phone last time
you seen the machine we stick the money
and and what the the great thing about
that movie like we had Rick Shapiro and
when we started assembling it for the
web series there were some people like
there was a guy at Galvez he giggled
through the whole thing like to me he
was likely he just giggled through the
like you couldn't even talk to him
because he just couldn't stop giggling
it was like here's a grown-ass man and
he would in would just giggle Jimmy
Schubert was just you know as as orange
as a carrot you look like Donald Trump
that's how embarrassed he would get but
it turned out that there were some
people because people are pretty funny
about the stories and talking about
deviance and then Rick Shapiro do you
know rich superior so Rick Shapiro did
the interview and his interview was so
real and he talked about how he because
he was kind of a deviant living in New
York as a young kid and he had a lot of
stuff happening to him and he talked
about during that time period about
being kind of his father was physically
abusive against him and how it turned
him into a deviant and and and when I
talked to susana after that and when we
looked at the footage it's like god I
really can't use this in like a comedy
web series because it's hard it's kind
of heartbreaking to even watch and then
Susanna was like you know when we did
that that moment had the most effect on
me because it made me understand because
when she when we got everyone to do it
right cuz I as a former stripper from
when I was younger you know what Here I
am filming someone who's a comedian
who's going to show everything to all
comedians that she respects and
this conversation with them and as a
woman I have to be very generous to what
she's comfortable with in what she's not
comfortable with and the amount to trust
that she had to have six seven cameras
on her while she's completely naked in
this mirror you were there it's like a
completely mirrored semicircle and with
glass and everything so nothing gets
hidden and to go through that experience
and and to see someone really be
profoundly affected by rich superior
story and understanding why she's
deviant and you know I can't just throw
any slob in front of her she's doing a
very personal thing she didn't want to
interview Rick Shapiro at first because
Rick was kind of known as a crazy guy
and could go off and she got really
nervous about I was like no this guy's
from the street we got to get people
that are from the street that understand
what you're doing and and what when I
appreciate it and when he came he was so
generous to her in spirit and about
sharing a real story where other people
didn't want to be you know sometimes you
get people right on your podcast and you
want to end there like all jokey jokey
all the time you're like you won't have
a real [ __ ] conversation every once
in a while so that's kind of what it was
where he was having the real
conversation and it totally shifted the
project and then when we were looking at
it I was like we can't use this in the
webseries but maybe we should put this
in as a documentary film about you
revealing yourselves as your real person
and what you do and and your struggle
and comedy and and how everyone
perceives you and what how everyone's
deviant how everyone's deviant in a
different way you know and I mean how
everyone's little twist is different
your twist is way different than Lee's
twist right you know but to explore that
and and to have women go sit through it
and have a discussion about it too as
well as men as well as you know someone
who's gay or whatever the situation is
and it turned out into a really cool
project so it's very curious when people
start talking about their first
experiences with sex like my ears open
up wide because then having boys
and hearing you talk about these stories
when my boys started looking at porn on
the computer and the therapist is like
you you gotta really supervise that and
try to shut it down as much as possible
because it really affects you do you
think going through this pretty life
your sexuality let me tell you something
with me it even you know I grew up in a
man's bar my mother had a man's bar so
the comments you know that was ten they
were already shooting comments happening
you know little you still piss and sweet
what are you doing mm-hmm you know house
how Cubans se are you coming yet you
know like they would say yeah my
girlfriend was gonna so it lifted my
curiosity that's when it lifted my
curiosity when I was a kid and those
people would ask me creepy [ __ ]
questions it was just I was always an
innocent before that I knew about it I
knew about you know I know about getting
a dick sucked in the first grade because
the kids in New York would talk about
mm-hmm you know that was the time that
was the era where kids were going and I
kissed some girls titties for a quarter
one time in the playground she put one
of those forty fives you know like we
were in the park and she's like for a
corner I'll let you kiss it I was like
Jesus Christ for a corner yesterday I'm
gonna go on home scratching my head the
rest of the day want to give a quarter
for that what happened what do you
think's gonna happen
you know like then then I was cool with
it and then that [ __ ] and then all of
sudden like the age of 12 they opened up
this valve on you like this valve opened
up on me and shortly after that I fell
in love but I didn't like the whole
sexual thing about it
I really loved this girl in fact all I
did when I was driving I never sucked
her titties nothing I could have taken
their titties I've never sucked in
cities never think of her every time I
would touch her would be through the
genes you know saying
so I wasn't really cause of the cab the
Catholic part of me
yeah he's [ __ ] yeah I started the part
of me challenging me yeah so the
Catholic part of me was scaring me I
already heard [ __ ] on the street well
you got to investigate this but not
really yeah you followed me I'm gonna
investigate this but very mildly I'm not
gonna be like the other [ __ ] savages
man and it was now that you talk about
it the different aids thing was like and
okay when I got to McKinley when I got
thrown on my Catholic so I went to
McKinley school so I was there the
six-way the seventh grade I used to hang
out of the 26th Street side and there
were these two kids that would work
during the week at their father's
whatever uh-huh what happened they were
13 and whatever they worked Monday
through Friday and then sadly they get
up and tell that mom never going to
Bergen life to buy clothes not really
they were got on a bus and had to a
Bronx or Brooklyn and go to different
prostitute houses and they will come
back to school on Monday so we were
young kids seventh grade Wow yeah and
his brother was a little slow his
brother was a little half a mo but in
those days they didn't put you in
different classes they just put me
together but since they were Cuban they
didn't really get learning the language
they were both of the seventh grade
together even though how Berto was older
than one but in Monday's we would gather
around and they would tell us the most
disgusting stories you heard me lie and
one would be the narrator but his
brother just called yeah oh yeah oh yeah
and they would break them the whole
thing we have into our house my chick
would approach him and then she'd bring
him into like a bigger type room with
him and his brother could pick the girls
then they'd go into different rooms that
she would take a bucket out and wash his
dick scrub it down nope this is my teen
service yeah yeah we were we were still
seven years away from AIDS yeah you know
we had no knowledge of AIDS what we
thought was we either get crabs that
little [ __ ] you got and you went to a
doctor they gave you pills you were
backflips like a dick will little wits
about the addictive same so that was it
so they would tell us how they would go
there and get I remember him saying
around the world the first time I
followed I laughter that was the first
person ever found that term so what do
you pay he goes uh ten dollars they [ __ ]
you straight they get on top of you [ __ ]
you do you come you come in them for
extra two dollars well you could wear a
condom like you know just [ __ ]
different prizes and then and then I go
like what else and then they go for like
15 you eat them the 2025 years around
the world you know as I did that one
time it was uncomfortable it was just
for 25 you getting around the world
yeah I wonder whatever happened to those
boys yeah nothing with them in high
school then yeah they won't like
mechanics or something they were very
good with their hands yeah so but for
that that's not what we're talking about
the main thing was that lifted everybody
around just curiosity but now we decided
how we were gonna do it you had no
options I can do it like them I could go
to one of those clubs in the city or I
could just get a girlfriend you follow
me so that's that's part of being 13 now
you decide how you want to do it that
tells a lot about you at the end 13 or
14 you know me I was scared of all that
stuff yeah I was petrified I avoided the
conversation like after the porn movie
I was done yeah I was done and then
years later I got involved in a car ride
but I couldn't get out of it was the
kids birthday and as I'm going I'm going
into 10:40 clothes Selam in the car with
them and now
said I lived it fully that night that
was the most disgusting thing that's
ever happened to me that was I paid $10
to get raped yeah like I left there I
didn't want to have sex for me to like
that's it well that's it the air also
and I don't mean to deflect from your
story because that reminds me no because
in I had a look at it that way I haven't
looked at it that way in a long time
because in the movie gene pompa shares a
story about going to a kids house and it
was a brother and a stepsister a
stepsister and that the brother would
make this and they were only like a year
or two apart I think there were like 12
13 14 ish and how they had sex and then
they kind of made gene have sex or
whatever and the way he was telling the
story it was a funny story but at the
end of the story you're like [ __ ] dude
that's molestation like that is you guys
are [ __ ] each other up you know what
I mean and obviously something's going
on at that house if they're dragging
someone else into it but when you when
you when men talk about things that
happen they tend to romanticize it and
make it funny but then when you have
them in an intimate moment and they're
sharing the story with you and the
funniness goes away you're like no
that's someone really molested you you
know and I don't mean it like everyone's
will listen everyone's right I'm just
saying it's no it should get different
you don't even get what you're doing
when I was on the fence 40 club it was
such a shocking experience that you know
like it was like that that's real for me
yeah I wasn't ready for a second that
what master reality by Black Sabbath
there's a little too real for me right
now my mom just died I just did [ __ ]
crystal [ __ ] THC the Exorcist is on
the other TV this is a bit [ __ ] right
well I would over to say that night and
I saw that degree of prostitution that
now has a 16 year old let's let's clock
it at 16 year old a [ __ ] calmly store
main room take the tables out take the
stage out
put two bartenders at each corner
selling the four light alcohols and soda
tastes like [ __ ] they cut the booze and
200 guys waiting they get dead dicks up
and there's 40 women in there oh it was
[ __ ] traumatized yeah and I also
learned about men if there was 200 men
in there a hundred eighty of those guys
that were very braggin though show these
are the guys in the corner that would
never [ __ ] a prostitute that everybody
wants to suck their dick they all had
Cologne on they all were done to the
nines spectacularly you know same way
they've all shaved their hairs and I
learned a lot that night on the other
side I love about a braggadocio man and
here they are paying $10 just how I am
and I'm not even sexually experienced
these were the guys that were always
sexually experienced and they had women
eating their [ __ ] ballsack
you know and all this [ __ ] and here they
are standing right next to me waiting
for the same [ __ ] dirty [ __ ] I'm
waiting on yeah like I left there that
night
disgusted manhood and disgusted in women
like that whole night just shiny like
and it was great it was a great age to
get disgusted that yeah at that time I
was maybe yeah like I said 16 maybe set
it down
I wasn't driving yeah I wasn't driving
it just say I know for my own self my
introduction to sex was all within my
own control because my parents at which
I feel very fortunate about and have fun
and fond memories of being a little kid
and my parents had in this box in the
hallway closet
true detective magazines and playboys
and I can remember from the age of like
8 to 12 going in and then once I found
it you know going in and just looking at
the pictures and really diggin and I'm
not into chicks anyway but just really
thinking how beautiful they were and how
like excited it made me feel you know to
me and so I I love that I had that
introduction gentle introduction to sex
like I have a friend who her experience
with that obviously was way way
different
and I'm always curious like how does it
affect people later in life their sex
life later and when I was 18 and I
started stripping for me it didn't
because I had such a my parents weren't
weird about sex and it was out in the
open my mother was German so like when I
was a kid we go to the park people
sunbathe with her boobs hanging out in
Germany when I was a kid in the 70s and
and so growing up and and without shame
involved with sex is a powerful thing
and when I was a stripper it it wasn't a
negative for me it was an empowering
thing for me you know what I mean
because I didn't have a lot of power
growing up and my parents got divorced
and you know everyone's it has a sob
story right but - at that time as a girl
no one gave a [ __ ] what you said or what
you thought you were just you know the
stupid girl and to then become at the
age of 18 a stripper and to understand
the price of cigarettes yeah the power
that you feel they're suddenly [ __ ]
listening to you I mean one out in one
ear not the other that's a really
empowering thing and what was so curious
to me when Susanna was first talking
about doing this project was like I'm so
interested in that with other people you
know like what her experience of that is
and because she's been doing like a
burlesque or stripping or other stuff
and I'm very curious how it why are you
laughing but how it affects her and
affects how people see her you know and
I mean the whole project was so
interesting in that we couldn't affect
guess who came to my show sound thanks
girl really that's a millionaire yeah
and how is she doing
you know she's always been a sweet kid
but I'm no [ __ ] Dax Baxter
you know I never claimed to be [ __ ]
no Gibson or what's the other guy Zach
was a good-looking guy is that guy from
yeah those that guy rough shape she's
still stripping I say she's thoughtful
but I I can't see anybody giving her a
dollar yeah why did you just give a
change it was not one enough when I was
a stripper as a teen there was this
woman and she and she was like 50 and
she would also always dance to men at
work the the the down under saw oh you
did my kids party like a kids party
he was the guitar player I went to look
them up on like wow but she would always
wear like that a weird bathing suit and
and she was like 50 something years old
and this little roly-poly lady and she
would dance to that men at work and
you'd be like [ __ ] I don't want to be
that chick scary yeah you don't even
love the wrestler she was great that she
played it really cool she knew she was
over the hill when she was competing but
she was still in there and I sell them
that little ass and one night they just
got through and she quit a job but she
did it it's a one of a weird thing to do
or not that don't like you and I have
had this discussion for years a
longevity of a stripper you know it's
three years and you get the [ __ ]
degree somewhere in the house I mean but
there is a toll
I see the toll drugs and alcohol that
[ __ ] speeds up your life bad quick
getaway you go from zero to [ __ ] 60
in a window yes we see it all that
shit's always shocked me I think that
were ruined me sexually was those years
of doing coke and [ __ ] having sex
oh really yeah I'm sure I think those
years [ __ ] me up because that blow after
six in the morning when you're just
throwing them around
I would just throw whoever I was with I
just roam around I wouldn't even talk
how he's just an animal you just put him
into position that's [ __ ] like there
and whatever and then he is later you
can't do that [ __ ] boy you can't they
throw you in jail for that type of [ __ ]
handcuffing people my moves time when
you guys were talking about walking into
the glory hole place in New York City
and how your feet would sink into it
reminded me the first time I walk is the
first place ever worked out I did a wet
t-shirt contest at the peppermint lounge
and and the first time I walked in there
and my feet hit the carpet that it was
exactly that were your foot look where
you could hear your foot crunchy right
it's crunchy but sticky at the same time
it's like and it smells that's the worst
smell on the planet without those places
and you know I want anything jerked off
a few times I mean sometimes you're
going after a good coke binge the whole
night you got that the old sperm in your
nutsack you thought you were gonna bang
this chick but also she hit you with
five in the morning which she had a
period that just started she didn't
think it was a good idea still a flop
and just not a late ball what is she
threw a curve ball at me so I gotta find
another victim and you get off the bus
and then you're getting like sex and
your mind starts racing you go in there
but I also would stand outside and just
look at the people that were going that
like right now okay where you shot this
was considered North Hollywood it's its
way deep in North Hollywood I'm like
okay I believe in that if you have a
conversation with Susanna she has four
regulars don't go in there
you know and I guarantee you the Posada
if 10 regulars seven and a half of them
are married
oh I'm sure yeah and you sit there and
look and go okay what what a married guy
wanna go and go into a booth with a
chick maybe spent 22 hours and singles
to talk to her
you're not really gonna have sex with it
right right you're on the other side of
an equation so you take your dick out oh
I can't think my dick out no more bears
no I think there's always a camera oh
yeah I think that goose out you show it
to your [ __ ] let's get the party
started what the [ __ ] oh yeah guys 28 to
35 I just took the helmet on clean the
length off right in the front I was like
I think the length on the turtleneck
right be funny
Oh arias how are you stop
you can't even pick your dick up no more
show it to someone say what else you
gonna do they're like you gonna shock
how long this did you well you know
what's so weird about that place is at
the Venus fair the backdrop of where the
men are sitting is actually marble white
black marble with white streaks on you
know like did they do this by design
well he's just done the party like
Felicia took the picture for this for
the documentary camera oh that's right
of your penis oh that's right that's
right and you know a cd-rom with my nuts
CV yeah if it's one of those things I
think I was a documentary one of those
yeah we were in the church we snuck into
the church and took pictures of it but
we didn't do the penis picture in the
church my girl in the corner and the way
I said it title Felicia got a mitigator
you can you never tell nobody nothing so
we should turn there I'll have my pants
down and I have my diction and I just
had my nutsack hang in there and she
just looked at them for a second I'm
trying to figure out the lighting
focus there was no hesitation she kept
saying Joey don't move but no and I had
those pictures on my computer and then
when my kids some and they were like I
think I might actually told them as they
were like woohoo are you going and I
think I said all right Joey had me take
a picture I think I told them which was
probably not comforting at all anyway so
but that place there is so crazy and to
have cameras going and people come in
while the cameras were going and to go
into the other rooms of the other girls
they didn't it's like you could point
they don't care that you want to get in
there get their business done but it's a
very interesting dynamic are you sure
are you allowed to take your dick out of
these places oh [ __ ]
oh yeah please for sure for sure yeah
but they have signs up that say no
masturbation but that's what everyone
does what are you supposed to do just
take it out and just that's weird they
do it right there and there yeah sofel
easy I like you've been a stripper and
then you've also been married like is it
what are you anyway were talking about
how some of his regulars are we're
married like what are you what's your
opinion on going strip clubs when you're
like marriage oh well because I'm at my
age where I am it's completely different
if I my opinion now as opposed to my
opinion being like 30 and married
Zadro just having a baby I probably had
pretty poor but to me it's kind of it's
I think it's different in different
cultures that you're in and I think I'd
be more angry about the money being
spent
then I would about you know meeting your
guy friends there and having a drink and
you know getting a table dance like yeah
that's kind of weird but I would be okay
and I've been on the other side of it
but I think I would be if I was married
in that situation situation and someone
habitually did that I'd be more mad
about the money being spent because it's
a lot of money right how much money do
people usually usually spend well it's
all different cuz when I did it I'm no
spring chicken so it was in the late
eighties and so it's all different all
over everywhere okay yeah you've been to
a strip club right how much did you
spend
no you've never been to a strip club no
are you serious ever net I just want to
pee if the other another but I haven't
been up in about three months
that's my little spot where is that
awful Laurel Canyon Barry oh yeah
open till 5:00 and when you go in what
do you do it's like do you have a whole
process I'm [ __ ] embarrassed yeah
it's like do you sit at the bar chat up
the ladies first as always those days
there's no bar there's a bar where they
sell water so you go over there you
gotta give them again gonna get bottled
water than receipt and you sit there and
you just watch and it's [ __ ]
described that doesn't get hard yeah
could I get a dance or something like
that
you know so when you go they're like
what is the the purpose of doing that is
it to relax
is it to relax I know I'm totally
somebody's [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you
haven't seen before
maybe ate an edible it went the wrong
way
yeah what you ate is you about to get
killed something now you're in the mood
to see somebody's [ __ ] [ __ ] ever
seen before
uh-huh and you go to the store you have
this burst energy guys and you know what
men
yeah I went from one extreme my life to
the other like I was one guy that would
you didn't know when I was coming in but
that was just me like walking a 10 I can
walk in at 2:00 in the afternoon or I
can walk in at 3:00 that night you know
now I'm home at L o'clock like that's a
way we got home 11:15 we stopped at yum
yum donuts yeah and if this mic sleeve
stays home and I'm back over the hill at
10:15 and you're like really really yeah
so you need to take leave and go to like
cheetahs you got a tape with cheese just
like on sunset that's when you filmed
this is not have yeah no I don't like
the sunset ones you don't know swing it
rather one of them Lybrand is the most
popular one in Hollywood that's where if
you go there five nights a week you'll
see movie stars in there you'll see all
the hot chicks the Kardashians go there
yeah crazy go crazy next to one Alana on
the bread and then the ones on was
Cienega and the one on Sunset before you
hit the purple veil the big veil
whatever the valve yeah that's always
been there since I moved here so when I
moved here I'm looking with a girl that
dance that the one on La Cienega and the
sevens red she'd switching between
Welton so during the weekends at night
she worked on La Cienega and during the
week she work at that seventh veil so
and she would go to work did did you
have any attachment to what she was
doing at all or you just kind of were
like you could compartmentalize it like
that's 18 months it bothered me but at
the same time I'd be a hypocrite because
she was giving me money to do comedy
that was always clipping her for 20 or
30 maybe 40 you know thank god you're
annoying
she put a bunch of money on the table
and go count it and I just dropped 20 s
on the floor and stuff on the whole you
gotta put the whole lot yeah when you
did that for 18 after 18 months Oh what
hypocrite you know I so I click in
little things happen did you treat her
different in the relationship because uh
you just don't know yeah but I was so
into calmly and cocaine that I shut that
part of my manhood off which never
really works that never really works you
pay for that somewhere along the line
either were saying I know I paid for it
somewhere after that along the line when
you shout your manhood against some but
I don't care for woman strips I really
don't I would never judge a woman for
that this thousand circumstances I'd
rather see that did you see that [ __ ]
white chick there down a little Canyon
collecting change that didn't look bad I
mean she wasn't she have a bicycle
because I saw her I saw her by the
bridge with a bicycle on the way down on
your side like if I go on Gelson's to
make the right okay we're both on the
same track blew my mind like what the
light and I looked at I don't know like
yeah that was unusual
that's unusual show my sweater on that
was really weird
you know I thought about my saw that Ted
Bundy I don't know why that's the first
nerve I can't believe I'm saying this
him like Ted Bundy would have a field
day with this [ __ ] money would happen
in that VW already in Vail Lima stabbed
in the neck by now yeah I get scared I
get scared for nothing you know what I
don't mind if we do that you don't want
going doors windows over here to victory
and shake that ass a little bit so what
you let somebody finger you for the
small 300 I'm going to tell you okay
they have like the downstairs like a
sign is it one of the times I went there
I saw a girl that listen to the podcast
like well the first time I went to a
strip club about three years ago I was
bored to pieces and it must have been
like quarter to eleven like if I go home
my wife passed out the whole house is
quiet I said there are [ __ ] cats you
could just do that so long
if that I can only get my dick sucked I
just want to see was crack-a-lackin'
that mouth [ __ ] yeah first time I was in
there with Mike there's nobody in here
kind of solo I thought this place would
have like valet parking guys in there
dancing and super being there was
creeping behind the shadows so I walked
out I went to the karna so the girl came
running after me come back I love you on
the podcast I watched on Joe Rogan come
on the girls know you all come on and I
went in there she dragged me after like
an hour or 30 40 minutes she dragged me
in front I will have a dance and it was
ok the dance was good she was putting up
[ __ ] on my jeans you [ __ ] like that
doesn't say that's all I kept thinking
about you rubbing your [ __ ] on my jeans
I got explained this older though you
know I'm saying that my [ __ ] jeans
Wow and it was fun but it was like and
then she started working me no there's a
room in the back we go upstairs and I
love all that [ __ ] that's why I'm Harvey
Weinstein oh I love negotiating with a
[ __ ] and for no reason yeah I'm one of
those guys like I'll just push it just
to see how you get yeah I'm a creepy
[ __ ] like that Wow
all is being revealed this happened like
at one time I was on the train I wish I
was on the phone with Josh wolf 1998 I'm
in New York City
I called Josh to see if I got mail me
and Joshua living together on sunset
with his girlfriend and along the phone
with Josh and all right listen man take
that check deposit for me please cuz my
shits about to bounce and he goes where
are you I'm on an ape train I'm going up
to Harlem to get some wheat and next
thing you know a chick's creeps up
behind me and she says tapped me on the
shoulder and she's like for 3,000 and
the light I see a guy that will go up to
Felicia no Felicia
yeah yeah he was saying you're white on
the right yeah yeah no I know
well if you were running for heard
you're on the floor like stuck up in
your ass but you were looking the other
way
would that take care of things for a
while
no I'm not one of those guys but if you
approached me with a deal
oh I sucked at it I want to know
particulars I want to know guarantee I
turn it to the why this guy you life I
don't put a list with glasses on being
even guarantee huh what can you
guarantee that you have know everything
I get is creepy as [ __ ] how's your dick
sucking abilities interview them
thoroughly
okay you know what do you need the money
for
does it get a point where they realize
you're [ __ ] with them never good yeah
oh I'll keep them I'll keep him on ice
just from my creepy mind to know because
I didn't approach that they contacted me
with some [ __ ] story right yeah we
would tell them what about Ralphie May
last week got restless salt when I was
in my house and then with Terry this
girl blue Terry and everything mm-hmm
and Guam me one night you listen I just
got a movie late to bought and Felicia
had 350 in my pocket we're live in
Hollywood had three thousand my pocket
maybe it's cause were somebody 1500 for
sag and I booked this project and if I
don't care that I can't shoot it and
send me my first guest star okay
let me issue this oh yeah what am I good
at this man had this back wall and we
got the co-star job back and the first
check I can I'll give ya awards to
co-star pay I think you pay 750 okay so
after taxes I'm getting 400 where's the
other notice how this is gonna get taken
care of they wanna know I'll book
another job a little in this silence
okay it was the creepiest thing yeah
there was salad she goes well whatever
maybe we could what do you say them
right when they open that door I just
attacked all right so listen so how good
is your little [ __ ] this when he told
me right now this is what's gonna go
down I go put out of this situation I
had her go uh-huh she's our only [ __ ]
not only go suck dick for 5000 do that
that's 1500 dick y'all saying you can't
stop with that little Filipino [ __ ] and
think I'm gonna go she was just broke
but the funny thing was she had been
working me she showed up in time on the
base current asked me for gas money and
she flashed that little dragon at me
right yeah and I saw it I was like no
this is not gonna go good no you know
she's playing with like she has no idea
so I'm gonna give her the rope but that
night I gonna go to hell listen so she
just so we're we're gonna meet
I don't want me that the Four Seasons in
Marina del Rey I know but we're in the
split here everything's gonna go down
it's just like yeah everything okay I
know call me back and allow Felicia I
forgot about it you know you forget
about zoning it so hard
watches 60 minutes to summon the phone
rings and it's Ralph eBay what are you
doing I'm downstairs let's go get some
reefer I run downstairs
Ralphie's caught two minutes in the
phone rings what's up buddy good to see
an awesome playing there we go
Rafi don't move the [ __ ] car I know
you gotta hear this I'll fill you in on
it later
I'm like what's up this is like nuts are
we gonna meet you're gonna meet I'm
rolling up the character and then I
listen to me I feel question nobody
asked me for this just goes so when is
it that you want to do in that right
there I had the opening I go go suck
your [ __ ] so when you like playing that
sack I go I want to light your ass on
fire and there was a beat as he goes can
I call you right back
I will she called back the money from my
uncle there's people I think there's
certain woman I think they got the pull
on you and I love when they show up
I kind of love when they show up and try
to pull like a I know sincere right here
you know I know
well that's so interesting about the
Harvey Weinstein thing is where I am
someone put on my face but what about
the women that complied let's let's I
want to know who complied what actresses
actually sucked to get up or [ __ ] to get
apart and I'm like I have no interest in
that like I don't like cuz if two people
are gonna have fun with each other and
do what they got to do I don't I care
about the women that say no you don't
know anything about Harvey Weinstein is
not this all on tape oh no I know
listen to me he's gonna come out and go
[ __ ] the weinstein company [ __ ] this
company [ __ ] that company I got tapes
little singer [ __ ] you don't say don't
you put together a compilation and
actresses in the ass gets him all cuz
you did [ __ ] a bunch of suppose there
was a bunch of message [ __ ] though who
would you need to do and they guest star
Rose how many movies eleven movie deal
stick it in wherever you are you know
he's a filthy animal he'd tapes some of
them so he's gonna come on and just drop
bombs
Wow these are the cow were at the
yelling no because that's what you know
what i guarante listen half the people
that spoke against them I just very
hypocritical no they knew what he was
doing for years and now that this boat
is sinking they jumped on it'd be
interesting what happens in that guy
comes out it was rehab he gets his story
straight that's gonna be [ __ ]
interesting well you just think about
like the type of person that does that
it's just a [ __ ] bully - he's 65 he's
loaded loaded boy but you know what you
never know actually have he's an Arizona
right now he's got three chicks and
don't even speak English
he's gonna kill him when he's done with
him - we know he's gonna come back and
he goes I'm healed and then they'd be
seasoned like him - no for an interview
he's a creepy [ __ ] do it all but Dad
they want it listen he's gonna have to
start out his story to somebody and that
dude's gonna come back with some creepy
[ __ ] stories because all his friends
turned on him at the end and he's in
there right now going that [ __ ]
she came over to suck my dick for free
Harvey OJ Simpson and they always find
the Freak Felicia yeah well most
predators do what a [ __ ] do you think
OJ's been nobody seen a picture of them
says he got a job he was playing oh yeah
I saw a picture he's having a good old
time he's he was up at the ranch no yeah
I just saw a picture was headed for the
race - what's going on with the ranch
that's it he's a sexual
monster Oh Jay he's been locked up for
11 years there's a white chick a blonde
look-alike right now he's [ __ ]
because that's what he was into all
those years all those chicks he [ __ ]
all those years afterward
all look like his ex-wife you know if
you watch the documentary Oh Jay in
America
the other one they were all bought the
one in Florida she was a cokehead you
had to see this broad just like the
[ __ ] chickie killed so yeah there's a
blonde chick right now getting drilled
by poor old Jack well I had a big fight
with my friend Alan and we had a huge
fight cuz he was like one of those girls
any girl that was in the hotel room at
two o'clock in the morning they ought to
know what's coming their way or whatever
and it's kind of like no not really
I mean maybe but that's victim-blaming
you know what I mean that's making the
victim feel bad and then I had another
friend who said you know when I was 18 I
was at Spring Break with a group of
people and we were all gonna go
somewhere and we're in the hotel lobby
and the guy that I had just met was like
I gotta go grab my coat
come with me real quick and then she got
you know in trouble in his room that way
it's like you don't you don't you don't
know like all the time what about and I
think about as young girl comics on the
road you have to share a condo with
someone what are you gonna say like if
something happens at 2:00 in the morning
you know like things happen and some and
you can't police where you are at all
the time you don't know you know I'm
very honest while the girls came back to
the hotel room I mean I thought they
were just gonna do a line of coke and
leave - yeah I took them in that lure
them into the spider's web well don't
say too much but you never know because
people are now so hypersensitive it's a
hard to joke about because people are
gonna that's why you know Bob wines see
now someone's pointing their finger at
the brother it's like well you know
everyone's gonna point fingers now [ __ ]
is crazy yeah it really is a crazy world
we live in an interesting at the same
time when you read the stories they're
not gonna make sense it's like who would
go who would like and not not the girl
like who would like think to change into
a robe made meaning yeah predator
someone who is used to getting their
[ __ ] way and be like get into a hot
like I doesn't even they don't even seem
real he pissed his father one check you
know it was just like jerked off in a
potted plant and like in the hallway in
a hotel hallway I've done that the hotel
Joe you said that the boy was overcoming
the plan looks thirsty you know you
shoot it right to the root next thing
you know the plane rose six inches
everybody's happy it's sunny in the
[ __ ] room or the plant dies and
that's the one marker wherever Joey go
Zapata hi guys sadly various nights I've
had a hate Quigley on him we discussed
different situations we put on our lives
and like I was very naive for years
until I got out of Jersey and then I
started meet the different being like
I'm getting my hair cut one day I'm 19
I'm a bustle of Colorado I live in the
house with three guys we got four
different bedrooms house is beautiful
and next door to us we got to chase to
the [ __ ] torture I'm talking about
torture from Milwaukee to Italian chase
dark both of them had so much hair in
their [ __ ] that I came out of the top
of the shorts the eighties nobody shave
that [ __ ] know they were it was over
she hush she had so when she put shorts
on one time and I saw the top rope [ __ ]
is almost fainted almost fainted the ID
Amory T I'm sitting on the phone I'm
sitting there minding my own [ __ ]
business as a young girl walks and maybe
18 years at all it was a degrees yeah
I'm sitting there minding my own
business girl didn't know it their
sexual brothers tight tight tight shirts
on yeah they were great
a white t-shirt uh no titties no broad
nipples popping right out very cute she
walked in to feel like an iced tea or
something but she had a sweat bead all
right a little [ __ ] walked right
through et when you can see where it was
sweating
hours you know what he's sure one second
and she just walks from [ __ ] just
[ __ ] them up her life why write that
Kate Beckinsale he invited her up to his
room and she was 17 you know everyone
has her twist but when you when your
compulsion becomes predatory and and the
thing is why I got this argument such a
big argument with my guy friend it's
it's like you don't understand me it's
not just men by the way but people that
are predatory they can sense who they
can corner you know what I mean they can
sense who they can as you like to say
but it's all down no I never thought I
would say something like this but look
I'm 54 I could tell you this I've met
six or seven female sexual predators in
my life that they act now today Who I am
today going wow I didn't see that yeah
we had a girl at my high school but I
can look in the face I can tell you
whatever story I wanted to be jokey with
you
she blew and [ __ ] every wrestler in
high school whether they were a freshman
sophomore and she [ __ ] him in the
wrestling room she was like the chick
from Sex in the City in Porky's the guy
was [ __ ] her up in the stands hey I
got one the hot one in the old one
she watched Porky's that's how giving up
that [ __ ] she looked good then too
but to this teacher for four years she's
gonna [ __ ] me cuz I didn't wrestle
mm-hmm but she knew that she knew that
help be hanging out doing coke with guys
we drop them off at her house
she'd opened the doorway about us like
you think about that today that woman
got a watch they auditor for like the
gym teacher of the decade she's a gym
teacher gym teacher today you think
about listen man I'm horny like every
other [ __ ] guy I got my own [ __ ]
sense right
I got no while and they were fall out of
a tree what a bag a Melendez I don't
like that I'm not a [ __ ] rapist
that's never been my game but I've had
some fun in my life either my the judge
Somali but there's some cold blood ship
that goes out there fishing you know
yeah once you put the fun lines and once
you see it like I would stay in the
bathroom just not one another pissed I
was washing my hands and well Mike what
can I tell Felicia you know I'm thinking
of them and I think awesome what my
junior year before I quit high school
that summer I was going through a rough
time financially but it was on my own
doing no don't feel sorry for Miss coz I
love cocaine the other thing I love coke
and every time we went out was $50 and
and the kids I grew up with had money I
didn't have money so I was trying to
keep up with that every [ __ ] night so
I was broke and I would you know I would
do what I had to do and this guy Lou
Donato asked me if I wanted a job being
a doorman and his massage parlor oh
really it was me right up the hill from
where I live I'm like yeah like he would
tell me every night just pick one on the
way out if you want to [ __ ] one of them
you know that aids like I just well i
something creepy like and I like sex
everyone likes that dick sucked and then
balls I mean everybody you know it's an
interesting thing as a woman to talk
about sex and having had the experience
of for a couple years working as a
stripper I mean I hate to it sounds so
bland when you say it
but I want people to understand like I
did like a wet t-shirt contest I won
money i won like three hundred dollars
in 1982 that's like a thousand dollars
now yeah it's like was so much money
again and then I did the contest a
couple times and the guys like no more
contest you're gonna work here and so I
remember and I and the thing that the
story is I was married right out of high
school to someone and then he became
abusive and then I had nowhere to go
and so the I went and did the wet
t-shirt contest and that's how I got
into stripping and I remember and this
goes back to you saying some women are
predatory when I say predators I'm not
talking just about men there are people
that are sexually predatory including
women and I remember I went down in the
basement to go to the dressing room and
I could hear like scuffling going on and
I turned the corner and it's these two
biker chicks like [ __ ] creek kind of
biker chicks like they were the tough
chicks like you can imagine in the 80s
early 80s and they were beating the [ __ ]
out of this young kind of fresh looking
strip and not much older than myself
I mean kicking her in the head beating
the [ __ ] out of her and I was all like
oh I don't want to purchase the food
right so I sneaked back up the staircase
and I go out into the club again and the
men and it was like 6 o'clock in the
evening because I was came to do my
first shift and the managers like I told
you get down there get dressed and I was
like I can't say to him some shits going
down because then I'm gonna be the chick
getting the [ __ ] kicked out of me right
so I remember sitting like on the
stairway and these chicks coming up and
they were like did you see anything and
I was like I don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about I'm just here my
first day right and those chicks were
predatory those chicks would steal the
Rings off men's fingers when they got
fingered I mean these were some seared
they their boyfriends were all bikers
these were like the biker chicks that
were stripping back then and so I
totally get what you're saying like when
gene pompa tells that story in pervs
about the fourteen-year-old girl who's
[ __ ] her stepbrother and then they as
a team are trying to [ __ ]
the girls predatory right like there's
some [ __ ] going on in that house but
both those kids are now being predatory
to gene papa and it's when someone tells
the story like that or when a man says
to another woman or sister than other
men oh I knew this chicken that chick
was you know wasn't me was it I totally
believe when men say that you know what
I mean some chicks are predatory
absolutely I don't think I've ever been
put more no no I'm not saying that I'm
just talking about women that I've met
that I've been around they years later
I've heard thousand stories in your way
oh yeah yeah yo Mike are you seriously
like oh my god you know you should see I
have a friendless predatory a really
predatory though they think about a
comedian chick oh and she moves and
waves why she or she just like a guy she
would move she would be a regular female
comic and then she'd go to an outside
bar afterward instead of going out with
the staff and she'd 0n I gotta go home
let the guy basically rape her app
arrest light a [ __ ] on me that was her
thing mm-hmm what she got hammered and
the sauna she never had to see the guy
that was her freak Wow years later we
heard the stories and we went back and
they're like what am i a blur oh no no
way you got to talk to you about
something buddy you came and she was
leaving yeah that night she had a
threesome she would pick random people
never at the comedy club she's very so
when you're that predator you know when
you're that's awful about the process
Wow
you're predatory yes okay so she's
gathered you know she would be right
here with us telling us I haven't gotten
laid in three years guys don't want to
hit up on me but then that night instead
of going to Hollywood have taken up
she would drive to Calabasas and gonna
like the dirtiest bar in Calabasas walk
head zero and like I take him home let
her do whatever and she get up before
the guy woke up and we'll never see that
person again she'd never even got that
neighbor again right right and I found
that he is later she was even taken
money in some towns of course she was
can you imagine later so now I'm
thinking about it yes she's very sex is
different for different people like like
when people are saying who did comply
who did [ __ ] Harvey you you know and I'm
like you know I give no [ __ ] yeah I know
people are so like what do you care
about I care about the women that were
actually harmed by this or felt
manipulated and all those tricks were
between the age of 18 and 25 I don't
give a [ __ ] of some chick likes to get
her freak on with some other [ __ ]
twisted [ __ ] I don't care about that let
me give some shoutouts here Bret be Cleo
nah smoke King Cara rot quad caste
Courtney Baba the Lingus one by one
podcast crystal oaks and bill patchouli
I think that's the name you know I love
you constantly a little twice
don't forget tomorrow night Lexington on
Broadway the party starts bring the
[ __ ] roller skates and the refund I'm
there all weekend [ __ ]
sorry about that never get this out
there at least I am what's going on with
you you're looking good I thought your
wife was leaving for three days no she
had the best business trip ever was like
ten hours but I have a funny news story
if you wanted hearing what there was a
restaurant in California oh yeah who
gives a [ __ ] yeah my chicken they were
serving chickens yeah it was serving
Popeyes - yeah how about the Freak that
was squirting all over children's flutes
in the school district did you see that
story
people are so weird [ __ ] that [ __ ] know
that uh that I was very interested in
when I saw the little parts of your
movie I haven't wanted to see how people
little react to it this weekend that's
why I wanted you to come love and
hopefully get some people down there cuz
their reaction thought like my reaction
to when I saw little bits and pieces on
the line I thought it was a great idea I
love the idea of the just a peep show
young honesty that goes in there oh yeah
cuz it's an art when someone shows you
their [ __ ] you you can't lie to that
person so late yeah that's a Showtime
late TV show okay the guy comes in every
week and it's cast around regular mm-hmm
and you put two newbies in there maybe
they become regulars later they come
back you know maybe she talks about the
sticking a finger up their ass they
break down and start crying and run out
of that and then they come back a year
later and you know Suzanne little bakers
like over you're gonna back you like
that little finger up the ass didn't you
[ __ ] he starts breaking down what
happened this is this is a great is
definitely like taxi cab yeah 15 minutes
one o'clock in the morning that's a two
two guests maybe a rotating guy this and
that it comes in and gives you a ton of
money lights his balls on fire does
something really creepy like um a cheese
grater on his nutsack and something like
that's something that people like what
the [ __ ] just happened and later on you
realize he's the CEO of a company that
makes a half a billion dollars a year or
something yeah but that's the
interesting part about it all walks of
life that go in there yeah from the
common drug addict to the successful guy
that's home that's been married for
thirty years and never cheated on his
wife but that's his little dirty secret
he's always has an out
there's a Glynnis between them mm-hmm
that's his out we talk about early
I walked them together magazine for a
friend of mine at work and I saw this
booth when I walked in and the chicks
showed me a [ __ ] and I put $2 and then
I told her that nothing class I couldn't
do anything
what are you talking about you're always
innocent it is interesting those guys
that do that one yes they really have
like an affinity towards a few of the
deserts there's guys that go to the
[ __ ] those guys that go to strip clubs
captain save-a-ho guys that go to strip
clubs and I'll put money on the thing
but never make contact with you even
though you'll pull out your thumb for
them to pull in they won't not down at
all yeah those are the guys those are
the guys that this is as evil as it gets
I love my wife this is as bad as I can
be right that's what's really I think
that years ago I read something years
ago that some people trying to get strip
clubs out of the town somewhere in like
Iowa somewhere was very Christian and
the argument was that it's proven that
in communities where the strip clubs
wore marriages last longer because the
common thread is that the guy's not
gonna [ __ ] his secretary the common
thread is if the guy's gonna come in
once every 60 days all right it's just a
fantasy
yeah I'm 50 you come you 23 you sit on
my lap I feel you tinny when I give you
an extra 50 you let me rub your [ __ ]
touch my back me just cut patting your
little monkeys or make me bust of my
[ __ ] pants and just that little
heartbeat to keep me saying hey
everyone's different everybody's
different everyone's different I get up
I go in the bathroom I wash my dick off
I gives a little black guy that gives
you a hand towel in there
look at my dick I'm gonna watch it in
the memory you know why should you will
drop your pants for anything so you give
this guy three four dollars right click
dick them because by the time you get
home you don't want no evidence you
clean the jizz off in the bathroom you
stop at the bakery you bring all your
wife flowers
I'm nothing after than nobody knows
nothing yeah and nobody's hurt right now
nobody's pretty a lot of people live
their lives like some [ __ ] somebody
whose lifestyle a lot of people they
just read a little bit Charlie and
nobody gets their feelings hurt
yeah after why you will tell you one
with the strip club to stop in there for
a beer but you go for them and that's
all yes you gotta marry me yeah but
you're still together wife knows you
ain't believe what you don't want to say
I do think you've met obviously you both
have Susana and I just think give her
she is so much like the biggest balls
ever that she did that that she had this
idea and then actually was able to have
really cool conversations and being so
vulnerable with being naked and all
season - somebody's gotta [ __ ] that
boot no stop he's gonna come from Island
gorillas [ __ ] just a good load on one of
those sad tattoos walk on there like you
own the joint
not that you thought about it you gotta
take me to a strip you guys gotta do
that so you can talk about it we can't
talk about it on the end because it's
not good trust me you don't want to know
last time we cross the street I really
don't know
and then they're not well here safe do
you ever just go wildly do you ever like
what's like not really well could he get
once again wild these manatees 29 is
really a buster but he wants to hang out
with Luke Skywalker and [ __ ] to Live
Crew well he saw that video his eyes lit
up because that's why I gotta hang out
with those guys he knows he's dying to
hang out with 2 Live Crew and your heart
thing I don't blame him just a between
Iran and what you live and learn you
know what would you want to be 29 again
and live through that whole thing again
no but one thing I do know if I was 29 I
fell in love when I got divorced like I
was such a [ __ ] like I was such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like I'm writing a book
and I was actually outlining that the
other day like Hello you said what the
[ __ ] is wrong with me
there was this bar and Boulder that I
was the host of on Tuesday nights and
the bold the broker tremendous on
Wednesday nights it was chicks 40 and
over that went there to suck [ __ ] and do
some well they called it a man I wish I
was lying - ok ok Boulder had listened
balda had this thing called FAC it was
on a rap a whole Boulevard it was at a
hotel there the Hilton who the [ __ ]
knows when it's called today in 1985
from 19 like 78 to 1985 playboy called
it one of the hottest spots in the
country if you wanted to get your dick
sucked on Fridays this was way before
valets when I Friday at 12 o'clock you'd
be driving in a rapaho and you could see
people already running to get like a
table and it was that much of a dick
sucking establishment that's what he oh
it was the bar at a hotel
oh really this was the chic place if you
were 25 and 40 you did blow uh-huh and
you wanted a son
they can talk about lies and talk about
your yacht and power and Houston and
[ __ ] just tremendous [ __ ] this was just
crazy [ __ ] which nobody even remembers
what else was there that I never went
that oh you never went in not one time
yeah what year is this this probably
went from 70 something to about 88 it
was popular oh really
remember at much coke there was in
Colorado I remember when I met Jeff out
Dez and he took me he said let's have
lunch is just comic that Joe hates and
for good reason and and we went to a
lunch and on the table and it's all
stockbrokers everywhere like a busy
place he would just pour the coke out on
the lunch and I was like people have no
idea what Frazee people have no idea
what 1983 88 was in this country yeah
and it locked down I went back to New
York
my buddy little Hannah coconut battle
and they asked him to leave I was in
shock I was liking you people serious
you know least the coconut tables
because I was a long time people doing
coca tables you ought to dessert you put
two lines of coca and you rolled it up
nobody said nothin to you I mean you
couldn't sit there like Tony Montana but
you could do it under control no you're
saying nothing I was crazy it was a
different second world ya know that ball
was was crazy but there was something
that I was gonna tell you about that
area like I'm [ __ ] now but that FAC
was hotter than [ __ ]
I mean there'll be droves of people that
did you ever go to the limelight in New
York the church yeah yes I went there
once when I moved in 94 right when it
was like it went to the end and that was
the career and I'd seen some crazy stuff
in that place what's crazy
that was crazy just everything's the
people arguing in math room so it was
like wow yeah I never went to know I was
crazy like Venus flytrap where you pay
$100 and people [ __ ] I never seen that
I didn't like that [ __ ] at all he used
to drive me crazy
like I said I worked for Louie de l'alma
massage parlor and there was a girl that
would come up to me every man she know
when he gonna let me suck your dick I
would hear to come up my head and I
believe there we like the one who wants
them to come on your hand we go does
this disgusting things like I didn't
understand so much about [ __ ] sex
that had met the [ __ ] girl that I met
in Florida and I thought was worth like
three months she told me a story that
for three years she had sex with a guy
and he paid her rent a car payment like
I might had almost exploded
I guess open-minded as I might have
almost exploded Wow because I've never
heard of such a thing
I had never heard of such a thing like
in my world that I didn't hear such a
thing what did he get in town for this
rent [ __ ] like a [ __ ] twice no
sex no he come over and buy a chocolate
chip cookies yeah he had sex okay the
stripper guy was married with a family
right with kids and he paid her nice
rent wanted a car pay the tuition oh my
god and he come over twice a week and
just do whatever he'd want for like six
years right what she got an education
yeah hey everyone's different everyone's
different you got a match just a dream a
reality
yeah no what are you gonna [ __ ] do
listen all that stuff man is what makes
that whole sex world cuz nobody knows
really what you're free cos nobody knows
yeah yeah sure yeah I never let nobody
get too freaked out at me like I wish
when I was 21 I went somewhere where
they were stuck sponges of my [ __ ]
Wow because at least now what I had
something I would have liked like
something differently or beads [ __ ]
with a mask on hang out with Tom Cruise
all wise shut you go to some house and
his chicks walking around with masks
alright one of those
no that [ __ ] ever happened to me like I
always got caught with the chick with a
disease venereal disease like that's
what I got some chicken after hours way
she make you a piece of [ __ ] with my
scratch from scratch de lisle the other
say what the kinkiest thing you've ever
done lead I don't know I mean I've
always been afraid of strip clubs I mean
I don't why are you afraid of me I feel
like there I feel like they the
strippers it's always weird in my it's
been weird to pay to get in and then
like you can't really touch them right
you could go and do whatever the [ __ ]
you want no in the strip club and I
always feel like I always feel like they
hate you they have the control once and
then they have the ones where because I
think even at that place they have
cameras but there's really nobody
upstairs you listen to me I like to cut
through the muscle of us I want a good
show
what's a good show means let the pieces
fall where they may
you ever say what do you mean by get
show like what are you tries to go
upstairs
what's the goal right to go we charge
tourists now you just want to negotiate
no I don't want to go Shannon what
happened um what goes on back there well
they have $60 a dance and they're a song
but if he gave me 80 I'll give you a
good man so what's in the dance
oh no one Kenneth I want to know what
I'm getting for my tax deducted yeah the
next thing you know she don't know this
research
yeah but know what you want to do my
family those all over him dismal knows
not nothing
but you're being personal situation we
get to go upstairs
it's 265 for I have fun
for 20 minutes what do you think what
was it a lot gonna happen but I'm the
type of dude then how do i what the
pieces foot the floor were then may
nobody says nothing we wrap it up we
clean that but nobody does nothing what
do you think the world good listen what
do you want to sixty imma throw your
bills I'm gonna hear [ __ ] worry
nobody go upstairs I'm rocking my
[ __ ] world absolutely
you go upstairs they do a nice dancing
I don't want let's don't hold on to her
panties for that long
I think I'm here to see Venus [ __ ] I
never had come here to see Victoria's
Secret I came here to see that [ __ ]
dragon of love you understand me
and then dance a little bit for nothing
like another 30 seconds then back that
ass up
what's that song by the black chick with
the [ __ ] up head to the English king
hold on roll up to the bumper baby no
the limousine come on dog no Nicki Minaj
no this is the bow put on YouTube roll
up to the bumper all right
look who this is you're gonna you're
gonna die all right okay and I want to
see the video Lee I don't want to hear
this song I want to see the video stop
look at me in the eye when you're
negotiating sex though you do it
actually turns women are it's like
you're mesmerized me six weeks let me
throw you the small three my chance is a
great job I mean but yeah put on great
you let me see this watch the video this
is Grace Jones he's the original Nicki
Minaj II know what Nicki Nicki Minaj
watch this what what speaking Malay look
at this this is style this is when we're
some women didn't give a [ __ ] and she
wasn't one of them look at this
[Music]
with this savage you think she gave a
[ __ ] Felicia
you
this is the UH Nazi she seems she know
about Trump before anybody oh my god
this is tremendous you know what you do
now go home and watch goober
you
Halle Berry robbing gifts Robin Givens
Halle Berry her the name of the
fragrance is like vagina
cuz it's her fragrance and Ike what do
you want it to smell like in there all
like we only want to smell minty in this
and Grace Jones has a mink on [ __ ]
throwing heat and the guy goes so what
do you think it should smell like if she
just looks at my scientists as she goes
let me tell you what it's just smell
like and she'd get something digs deep
and picks up a long black legs and takes
a little fun you're the scientist right
this face and he said there with the
underwear displays and he doesn't even
want to touch the other way he goes like
this and he goes I quit right Eddie
Murphy catches them now they're trying
to see what to do with the other way
Halle Berry pushes the underwear way and
some other guy takes it and passes a lot
for this guy and that guy takes in
passes my first guy and all of a sudden
when we were kids the 7up guy uh-huh
young cool the black big black dude that
was bald he appeared the couple James
he took the of the way bullies are
always a pleasure to have you thank you
very much what Friday night 6 o'clock 6
o'clock Friday night at the Regal
theater come see and my movie perv
starring Susannah Lee has Felipe Esparza
Joey it's a nice place around it you
could eat so get down there early take
your wife out to eat
bring a glove with you in case you want
to bang one on the movie theater case it
makes your back that was another place I
went to that shocked me as a young man
I went to a button this happens to a lot
of people and this isn't talked about
either but this happens a lot I never
even spoke about
now am i affected by it no but looking
back it's a reality one night what
hanging out on a Saturday night Baba
what are we doing tomorrow I'm in watch
football holiness we were in high school
I gotta be like I had dropped out but
these guys were seniors I had Sunday
night's awful one night some mangoes why
don't we go to whatever was I don't know
what the name of the town was maybe 20
minutes away
and when Sunday nights are like an old
movie theater they showed porn and I'm
like absolutely I've never went to a
porno movie theater and I haven't seen a
porno in years there's a bunch of guys
that you drink in there you could drink
you smoke dope and ask the word on the
street let's go down there
I totally go down in and be like mixed
[ __ ] dark creepy the floors were
sticky and you go in the bathroom every
time you go in the bathroom the same guy
would pop up the end and the journal and
he glanced over at your deck for a
little while and then he like bumping
Tiye that make-believe like you because
I could see a Dickens full of you
Felicia tremendous yeah you don't know
what it's like to get bumped by a guy to
see you dick did you negotiate with him
no just ran into a bathroom then he
bangs it out in there oh really like it
was one of those guys that was his king
that was his kick and you know where
else I saw that San Francisco at what
1985 oh really like a congressman how
they did it was a wide open there was no
pink of an airport with no TSA there was
nothing yeah if Felicia was flying I
could walk up to the gate in those days
yeah that's how wide open flying was so
I'm never forgot I was stuck on Apple in
San Fran for seven hours SFO and I saw a
guy in the morning that I thought was
looking at my dick hmm you pop and then
he pops right up next to you but then I
wash my hands left about three hours
later I see the same guy in the [ __ ]
back I see him walking the bathroom is
what this guys doing
sure enough I go up there Jesus he fell
for the bait he comes next to me he
stands next to me he's peeing he ain't
paying and he's out of pee he's just
looking at my dad
and then finally one with the wash my
hands and watch them in the mirror and I
watched how he would it was [ __ ]
tremendous you were going to urinal
jerk-off go back look at his man's dick
check off he would do it like three
times then go get something to drink
and that's the moral of the story of all
the story I see you [ __ ]
Lexington Kentucky Thursday Friday
Saturday what's up Doug well doing
though yeah don't worry but I had this
don't stop young people I'll see you
this weekend Lexington Kentucky and
don't forget there's the week of your
life all right
you got [ __ ] baseball you got the
Yankees against Houston what tomorrow no
Friday yeah they're taking a day off
tomorrow tomorrow they're flying at
Houston that means Friday and Sunday or
Friday and Saturday they're gonna play
in Houston and then you got the Dodgers
check the Dodger score what's going on
with the dye thing and footballs kicking
off at footballs kicking off listen to
me Escobar basketballs on right now if
you're gonna make some dough Remy this
is the time to do it why make picks and
tell your buddies you want a parade if
you ain't gonna win no [ __ ] money all
right if you're watching the game it's
time to make money Oh what happened
Chicago's 1 3 2 2 so it's perfect it's 3
2 1
anyway my bookies the industry-leading
web site that hooks you up with all your
betting needs and with their great odds
fast payouts and decades of expertise
you can bet with confidence your team
doesn't even have to win they just need
to cover the spread
what are you waiting for lay down some
cash and win big if you if your team
sucks do yourself a favor and bet
against them like some people should do
if they lose you'll make money and if
they win you'll still be happy where you
bet is as important as what you're
betting on that's why I'm urging you to
make your way to my bookies got a G I
trust them but I don't have to take my
word for it check them by yourself they
have in game live betting and mobile
site that makes wagering
on the go easier than ever you can also
check out their online casino if you'd
rather just play a few hands of
blackjack or roll dice of craps take
only knock yourself on go join now and
my bookie will match your deposit with
up to wanna percent the bonus did you
hear what I said to join now and my
bookie will match your deposit with up
to a hundred percent bonus just use
promo code Church CH you are CH to
activate the offer visit my bookie dot
AG use promo code Church today
plain and simple you ready you play you
win you get paid I also want to thank on
it the industry leader is supplements
alpha brain your little [ __ ] up lately
maybe you got kicked in the head maybe
you need some [ __ ] clarity go get a
jar off a brain I guarantee it'll help
you get one hundred percent money-back
guarantee and we don't want the product
you delivered right to your [ __ ]
house that's it and that's that again
my bookie jg again honored calm I want
to thank Felicia Michael wish you luck
and congratulate it and I want to thank
the [ __ ] you know I love with
all my and I want to thank you
[ __ ] for supporting the show
see you next Monday have a great weekend
stay black speaking of some dirty
animals here you go